two years ago teacher Maria antonieta
santivanez took part in massive
demonstrations to demand a new
constitution for chile when written by
ordinary men and women not discredited
politicians
the draft that followed was ultimately
rejected nine months ago as too radical
now like many others Maria antonieta
plans to annul her vote when she goes to
the polls to choose a new much smaller
Constitutional Convention
last time we could propose ideas for the
new constitution we elected people from
all walks of life not politicians this
time there's none of that so I would be
betraying my principles if I validated
this process
[Applause]
80 percent of Chileans wanted a new
Constitution that would guarantee Better
Health Care education and pensions and
more Equitable wealth distribution
many also wanted gender parity rights to
abortion cutting-edge Environmental
Protection and greater indigenous rights
this second crack at changing Chile's
1980 Constitution that was written under
the former military dictatorship has
been overshadowed by disappointment
especially by those who wanted major
structural reforms this time round both
the rules and the candidates have been
decided by traditional political parties
and Congress from the far left to the
far right in front of the presidential
Palace center-left candidates tried to
capture voters attention
goes the extra mile by borrowing a
street musician's drums
he's confident that a commitment to
guarantee basic social rights in the new
text will be respected
given the Constitution that we have this
new version is a major step in the main
objective of fighting inequality in
other words we need to advance six steps
but will probably only go three but
those three are very important
conservatives who are likely to win the
majority of delegates will focus on
maintaining Chile's free market economic
model
this will be a constitution born from
the failure of the previous draft so we
can't expect major changes to determine
the future but we can expect a greater
opening of the political process that
was lacking in our transition to
democracy most voters still appear
undecided on whether to see this second
chance for a better Constitution as a
glass half full or half empty Lucia
Newman Al Jazeera Santiago